こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんユーチューバーいろいろたくさん人がいると思うん
ですけども
ランチもの湯チューバーやってると思うんですけれども皆平州というものをしています
で僕のよくあるんですけどもヘイシーの中で水をします僕は特にしますよ
youtube の中にはいろんなユーチューバーの動画があるんですけどもその中で
も数々のミスがあるでタバコの動画はひょっとしたら言う
チーム見てる皆さんのコーチつかもしれないして youtube やってる人もそう
いうのあるんだってな感じで今日構えることができるかもしれないんですけどもう今回
でそう youtube 編集の中である編集水上がるというものをちょっと僕の経験
および他の唯一ある動画見てて思った
この編集ミスよくあるなんてねちょっとまとめてみたのであそういえばこういう店も
あるんだなみたいな感じで見てくれる
嬉しいです a子ん
[音楽]
ban
ああああああ
ran
マサキの
家の中で
ロケット花火8
[音楽]
あげてしまい調査の皆様に迷惑をおかけして
大変申し訳ございませんでした
こちらゴキブリこのゴキブリを今寝てるんですけどもはぁゲットの枕元においてこれ
置いておくとターゲットどんなリアクションする
2時代にやっていこうと思いますねずむせ嫌いなんで絶対いいリアクションすると思う
んで木場まりないです
やっていきましょう
よっしゃん右手なぜたこれ
こんな風景仕掛けるから寝てていいよ
梅開けちゃダメでバレちゃうんです
前髪を
こっちに流しつつ
こっち側ね
上にかけてスッキリー
させて
今回ですね最高を3つ準備してこの3つ振ってブロック66って録画ん3つ連続で出る
の10連続繰り返しまで寝るが店ですごい風ですよ
これはもうマジ楽しい入ってる
me
ん
こんにちはー
winner tv です
今
膀胱炎に来ていますう末にはそこに
あの子さんがいつも公園いる今回から絶対絶対あいつ
つかまえて
うん
やってやります
後藤つ限定のラーメンを食べていこうと思います
あのつーかそっちの方に美味しいラーメン屋さんがあるみたいなのでまぁそうですね
京都つけてどみそラーメンとかを食べたいなという気持ちなんでまーすラーメン食べて
いければいいなと思っておりますでは早速
すすっていきましょう
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ